oui
après un concert de sélection au palais
des congrès de versailles en avril
dernier et quatre finalistes de cette
édition du versailles live casareccio
enoch telegraph vernis rouge se sont
retrouvés pour une finale musicale à
l'ambiance détendue
j'espère que la soirée sara radieuse on
est un groupe d'amis depuis très
longtemps on adore faire de la musique
et puis versailles nous a permis de
faire ce très bel événement et on est
super content on est super excitée on
n'a qu'une envie c'est d'y aller non on
voit surtout l'ambiance qui est
incroyable et ça faisait vraiment
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas vu déjà
autant de monde et en plus autant
d'énergie ouvert à toutes les villes de
france et à tous les styles musicaux
versailles live se présente comme un
réel tremplin pour révéler et propulsé
ces jeunes groupes empli d'espoir
[Musique]
versa live son nez dès vendredi du rock
qui existe à versailles depuis plusieurs
années qui en fait sont
voulue pour être des tremplins pour des
jeunes groupes de versailles et
d'ailleurs pour émerger donc à la fois
proposer des concerts aux versaillais et
en même temps faire émerger des groupes
de jeunes c'est cool qu'il ya des villes
qui se bouge un peu pour les artistes
comme versailles donc c'est super c'est
toujours un tremplin de jouer devant du
monde de jouer devant des professionnels
aussi parce que le jury est constitué de
professionnels de la musique c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir un retour
sur notre musique sur notre prestation
scénique pour avancer à l'issue de la
soirée les votes du jury et du public se
sont portés sur casar et duo l'occasion
pour le groupe d'obtenir un coup de
pouce médiatique et une diffusion
gratuite de leur musique le but c'est
que le gagnant ensuite gagne des
partenariats avec nos justement nos
partenaires qui vont leur permettre
d'être publié et d'être diffusé sur leur
plateforme pour prépare des choses des
choses qui nous font plaisir et donc on
est là pour avant tout faire de la
musique dire ce qu'on a envie de dire et
puis si les gens adhèrent tant mieux
mais s'il s'avère pas au moins on est
entre nous versailles live a su attirer
un grand nombre de personnes un constat
qui fait plaisir après un premier
concert de sélection sans public
non